There are folks that run
away from the sound of battle.
And then there
are folks that run
towards the noise of the guns.
We are those guys that
move towards danger.
That's our job.
[gunfire]
We're moving this way.
I've served with a lot
of great men, great women,
but that particular group
have become my family.
You know what else
I've been thinking about?
It's what we should do when
we get out of here, man.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I always wanted to
open up a guitar shop.
We'll just hang out,
play some awesome tunes.
We'll even get my dad
involved, you know?
Make it a whole little
family business.
Yeah.
I never had a brother
before you, so--
BENJAMIN MAYHURST: Multiple
times, I know guys put
their lives on the line for me.
And I know there
were times when I
did the same for other people.
And that doesn't go away.
For right now, on this
roof, my responsibility
is to the safety of
all of these men.
OK?
Everyone.
And I need you here with me.
You understand?
I need you.